so for last talk we have
liia also from
the
against
take
okay yeah let's try
us
let
yes
okay apologies for the delay let's see
does this
work thank you um um so I'd like to tell
you about uh the connection between uh
robustness of data Corruptions and
differential privacy which uh this paper
was joint work with hilala AI and
Jonathan
Alman um so we're thinking about the
general setting of statistical
estimation where we have some
distribution D we want to learn a
specific parameter of that distribution
think of the mean for
Simplicity um and so what we want is an
algorithm which given uh training data x
uh return something that is close to
this parameter that we want to estimate
and so two very common derer of machine
learning
algorithms are differential privacy
which says that in the process I
shouldn't leak too much information
about the training data set X and
robustness of data Corruptions which
says that even if someone corrupts a
part of my data set the output should
still be somewhat
accurate and and a bit more formally um
just to introduce the parameters uh
Epsilon differential privacy says that
um if I have two a pair of data set two
data sets that differ on a single data
point but are arbitrary otherwise um the
probability that I see any one output
under data set X should be close to the
probability that I see the same output
under data set X Prime so my algorithm's
output shouldn't change too much if I
change one point in my training data and
Epsilon measures the Privacy loss the
smaller Epsilon is the more private my
algorithm now robustness says that if I
draw a typical sample X not worst case
this time just a well- behaved sample
from a distribution D but someone an
adversary oops sorry comes in and
corrupts a fraction towel of my data
points um then the output of my
algorithm should still be accurate on
any corrupted data set so the output
should still be close and I measure the
accuracy with Alpha of too because the
accuracy of the robust algorithm would
depend on the fraction of Corruptions in
its
input and so the two Notions you can
tell how they're intuitively close uh
they they say that the algorithm should
be insensitive to changes in its input
but formally they're quite different
what we've known for a long time is that
differential privacy seems like a
stricter notion it says we know that
Epsilon differentially private
algorithms are inherently robust to a
small fraction of
Corruptions um but in the other
direction things were more fuzzy um we
had several optimal differentially
private algorithms in the literature
that the way people came up with them
was uh by being inspired by the
equivalent robust algorithm for the
task um but in a general eneral tailored
way to every task at
hand so what we did is asked the
question can we come up with a
systematic way to take any robust
algorithm and turn it into a
differentially private
one and this is the punchline of this uh
work the answer is
yes given blackbox access to a robust
estimator you can always construct an
Epsilon differentially private estimator
for the same task
maybe maybe that's not the surprising
part um the surprising part is that you
can relate the accuracy of your
differentially private estimator to the
accuracy of the robust
estimator and specifically the accuracy
of the Epsilon differentially private
estimator we construct um is
uh the accuracy of the robust estimator
for a specific number of Corruptions and
you don't have to care about the
specific uh the specifics right now but
the number of Corruptions depends on the
size of the parameter space and the
number of points and the Privacy
loss um so the good thing about this is
that this is a general transformation it
works every time and the accuracy
guarantee actually we can show that uh
tells us that the transformation is not
lossy so in low Dimensions the
differentially private algorithms you
get from this we can prove that are
always optimal and in high Dimensions we
can show that there are several problems
for which the transformation is optimal
so it gives you an optimal
differentially private algorithm if you
start with an optimal robust
algorithm uh and finally we can get like
a more General conceptual result between
um Epsilon differentially the
equivalence between Epsilon differential
privacy and log n over Epsilon n
robustness um in the sense that the the
min max eror that you can achieve under
both uh conditions is exactly the same
for low itional
tasks thank you very much um know if you
have any
questions thank you very much so uh yeah
May
we'll we take a short break now and meet
here again at 3:15 for the
next thanks for